I I feel all the problems of the hookup
culture and the talking culture and all
all the problems you're describing are
because there's so much uncertainty and
nobody has any idea what the hell
anybody's supposed to do because there
are no standards and there are no Norms
we don't even know what a man is and
what a woman is anymore we don't even
see depictions of this that we can
emulate and so I think you know we're
all we're all complaining here well I'm
not about how we don't want things to be
black and white but if things were a
little more black and white if we had
Clarity on some of these issues then you
wouldn't be getting into marriage like
Brian is worried is this woman going to
take my kids and half my stuff you
should go to another country it's much
more black and white it is I know yeah